vsauce kevin here with two known
criminals and we have to find out who's
most likely to re-offend is it the
teenage girl who stole a neighbor's
scooter and wrote it around her
neighborhood before dropping it on a
lawn and walking away or the 41 year old
male who's already been convicted of
armed robbery who do you think is more
likely to commit another crime
the answer is
it doesn't matter who you choose
algorithms are being used to determine
future criminals one widely used in the
united states is likely to label the
scooter thief as a higher risk than the
actual violent felon and the supreme
court decided
if the algorithm gets it wrong
it doesn't care
that scenario is actually real on a
scale of one to ten measuring a
criminal's likelihood of recidivism
whether they're going to commit more
crimes in the future the teen scooter
thief was raided and eight the seasoned
armed robber was rated a three
predicting who will commit a crime has
been an inexact science for centuries in
the late 1700s viennese psychologist
franz joseph gaul ushered in the era of
phrenology the theory that bumps on your
head predicted personality traits george
comb even identified three skull shapes
that not only predicted criminality but
determined whether the person should be
held responsible for their criminal
actions but do you know who's most
likely to commit a crime people who are
already criminals it's common sense to
factor criminal history into sentencing
to protect society the more crime you've
committed the higher the likelihood that
you'll commit more so the more time you
spend in prison but judges and juries
are human it can be difficult to tell
whether someone can be rehabilitated or
whether they've already learned their
lesson and we can't just guess there
should be a fair unbiased risk
assessment algorithm to counter the
shortcomings of human judgment what
we've got might as well be head bumps
and skull shapes equivant's website says
software for justice you make decisions
that matter we make software to support
them we're advancing justice one step at
a time when the company was known as
northpoint they developed compass
software correctional offender
management profiling for alternative
sanctions it's one of many risk
assessment tools used by new york
california and a range of municipalities
to help courts assess an offender's risk
of recidivism
the assessment works like this
defendants are asked over a hundred
questions about their criminal history
family and educational background work
history and lifestyle all things that a
century of social science research in
psychology and criminology have shown to
correlate with anti-social behavior
compass's result is a simple score on a
10-point scale with 10 being the highest
risk of reoffending everyone has an
actual compass risk assessment including
me let's find out how likely i am to
commit a crime real quick let me tell
you how i lost five pounds by basically
playing a math game what yeah about a
month ago noon reached out about
sponsoring vsauce2 and i said sure but
only if i can test it out so here's what
i do i told noom i wanted to lose 5
pounds and it gave me a calorie target
for each day i weigh in on the scale
each morning i log what i eat for
breakfast lunch dinner and some snacks
and i follow the gold they do have
coaches to help you out but for me i
just follow the numbers you can also
track your steps track your water intake
and just get an overall numerical sense
of your daily health and goals i've
tried tracking this stuff myself and it
never worked new makes it easy to stick
to the plan if you want to try a new way
to get healthy then take a free 30
second quiz right now noom.com
vsauce2 link down in the description
below that's noom.com
vsauce to use my link then they know
that i sent you and thanks to them for
sponsoring vsauce2 okay so am i a danger
to society let's take this test and find
out arrest for violent offenses no drug
trafficking no prison probation parole
gang member no this seems pretty
straightforward and saying yes to any of
those would probably predict criminal
behavior do you live with friends no but
what if i did i used to lots of people
live with their friends because they're
friends i always behaved myself in
school agree or disagree i mean most of
the time yeah definitely and
do anything crazy i
did get detention once for writing an
inappropriate poem
really was not a very nice poem but does
that poem really have any bearing on
whether i'll be a criminal as an adult
what delinquent mistake did you make as
a student
can you verify your employer yes how
often do you worry about financial
survival often sometimes or never i
would think almost literally everyone
would say often
how often do you feel bored do you feel
discouraged at times is it difficult for
you to keep your mind on one thing for a
long time have i felt sad in my life
have i played sick to get out of
something to get ahead in life do you
have to put yourself first do i always
practice what i preach this is starting
to get kind of weird lots of people feel
bored or sad sometimes
what does any of this really indicate
and this criminal attitude section has a
lot of questions that have a range of
valid philosophical answers like whether
the law helps average people whether a
hungry person has a right to steal or
whether victimless crimes like
recreational drug use are actually
crimes to get my score my answers to
these 137 questions would be fed into an
expertly developed algorithm that looks
something
like this
a total black box
no one knows how the algorithm works at
all we do know that their formula for
assessing the risk of violent recidivism
is risk score s equals current age a
plus the age at their first arrest plus
history of violence h plus vocational
education scale plus history of
non-compliance with every single term
adjusted by a negative or positive
weighted multiplier oh and according to
compass weight given to multipliers is
quote determined by the strength of the
item's relationship to person offense
recidivism that we observed in our study
data makes sense right wrong
if you'd like an explanation of how that
determines someone's violent recidivism
rate guess what so did eric loomis in
loomis vs the state of wisconsin eric
lewis pleaded guilty to fleeing a
traffic officer and operating a vehicle
without the owner's consent he protested
that his due process rights were
violated by the black box that is the
compass algorithm he was sentenced to
six years in prison influenced in part
by his compass rating and his appeal
went all the way to the u.s supreme
court they declined to hear his case and
the inner workings of compass continue
to be proprietary and protected by law
as a trade secret the united states
sentencing commission which i
highlighted in my last video also
declined to investigate whether risk
assessment algorithms were valid but
propublica
did they highlighted that ridiculous
outcome of the scooter girl brisha
borden and armed robber vernon prater
their investigation found that compass
was spectacularly
inaccurate by under predicting the rate
of reoffense by white defendants and
over predicting recidivism by black
defendants two years later borden hadn't
committed any more crimes and prater was
serving an eight-year prison term for
stealing thousands of dollars of
electronics but the problem isn't just
compass in a meta-analysis of
algorithmic approaches to predicting
recidivism eight out of nine of them
didn't work an article in the harvard
data science review said we're in the
age of secrecy and unfairness
exactly the problem that risk assessment
tools were created to solve how bad are
these supposedly advanced tools you
could get the same results by polling
twitter researchers from dartmouth
college showed 400 random volunteers on
the internet sets of 50 descriptions of
defendants age sex and prior criminal
history they predicted whether each of
the 50 would reoffend within two years
of their last crime their median
accuracy was basically the same as
compass
reddit and twitter are just as good as
the algorithm and no court would take
cash money spongebob avatars as
authoritative do you seriously think the
supreme court would ignore trial by
twitter and a researcher at duke
university found that a simple
calculation involving a defendant's age
sex and prior convictions
also yielded the same predictive power
as compass
so
what are we even doing
equifen has recently updated compass to
address some of the criticism which is
good but
what's the real problem here
is there a limit to how we can use data
as a replacement for personal judgment
is human nature too complex and
unpredictable to be supplanted by an
equation are we too ignorant of what
leads to recidivism to build a useful
predictive model
or are we just still in the infancy of
this technology and will ai help bridge
the knowledge gaps that currently ruin
lives
is predicting human behavior just
something we
can't math our way out of
[Music]
and if we could
should we
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you